PROFESSOR: OK.
So we have set up the problem.
We now have to understand
what is the physics
of this f of theta and phi.
In a way, solving this
scattering problem
means solving for
the thetas and phis.
Now, you would say, OK,
that seems reasonable.
You know how the
solution looks far away?
And that's where you're
going to do the measurements.
That's where you
have the detectors.
So we have to find what
f of theta and phi is.
But suppose you had it.
What have you learned if you
have the f of theta and phi?
So this is what we
need to compute,
and we will build towards
the computation of this using
what is called partial waves--
waves and phase shifts.
This will allow us to calculate
the f of theta and phi.
But doesn't tell you yet
what f of theta and phi is.
So the nice thing of
this f of theta and phi
is that it gives you the
cross section of the process.
So we need to understand
what is the cross section.
So what is a cross section?
It's a way to quantify the
effect of the scattering
center on the particles.
Suppose you have your
scattering center
and you shoot particles in.
Then you can say, OK, let me--
let's see with my detectors
how many particles go off
at an angle theta?
When you say three
particles per second,
I'm finding as you
should in particles,
I'm getting three
particles per second
in this detector at this angle.
My detector at this angle
covers a solid angle of 100,
and it's getting three
particles per second.
Then you can say, OK, what
is the area of a target that
out of the incoming
beam captures
three particles per second?
And maybe-- there are lots
of particles coming in,
but if you produce
some area, that area
will capture three
particles per second.
And that would be what we call
the differential cross section.
The value of the area
that captures or just
whose flux of particles
is precisely what you're
getting out there.
So if you're looking at some
process in which there's
this incoming particles and
you look at some angle--
d omega-- where
there's a detector,
a detector that
capture this angle,
you can associate to
this object and d sigma--
which is a differential
cross section--
with units of area.
And the physical interpretation
of the d sigma for this--
the omega-- is that
sigma is the area that
captures the amount
of flux that you
see going in this direction.
So it's a way this area--
this differential cross
sections-- give you
an iv, or a concrete
representation,
of how big the target is as
seen by the particles that
are coming in.
I'll write it in a way
that makes it clear.
So d sigma, which is called the
differential cross section--
is equal number of particles--
there's lots of words here,
but it's good to write them--
scattered per unit time
into the solid angle--
d omega-- divided by the flux
of incident particles, which
is equal to the
number of particles
per unit area per unit time.
So it's this ratio.
Number of particles
scattered per unit time
into solid angle, d omega--
particles have no units.
Integers scatter per
unit time is 1 over time
into the solid angle-- d
omega has no units, either.
The solid angle floods of
incident particles is--
particles that has no
units over area over time.
So here you had over time,
here over time, they cancel,
this is 1 over area.
That ratio, therefore,
has units of area.
And this is what
I was telling you.
The differential
cross section, which
is an area, multiplied
by the flux,
gives you the number of
particles per unit time
that are crossing at
differential cross section
area.
And those are set
equal to the number
of particles per unit time that
end up within this solid angle.
So for a given
little solid angle,
you get the d sigma,
which is small, as well.
That's why it's called
differential cross section.
So let's try to show that this
d sigma is really determined
by f of theta and phi.
This angle-- solid
angle, d omega--
is happening at some
theta and some phi.
That's a position, the center
of the little solid angle.
A solid angle, d
omega, at theta phi.
So this is our goal
now, to just calculate
the differential cross section.
OK.
So we have to
compute this fluxes.
We can do it here.
Now, we're not working
with wave pockets.
We're working with
energy eigenstates,
and we're going to have a
little bit of a fun intuition.
We're not-- we're
going to get it right,
but you have to appreciate
it's a little funny.
If I have a little
volume, and I say
that I find the probability
to find the particle there
to be 1/2, I would
say that there's
a half of a particle
in that little volume.
If I have a volume
that whose probability
to find a particle is 1, I say,
OK, I have 1 particle in here.
That's the rough intuition.
So for wave functions
that are not normalizable,
it's almost like--
suppose size squared
is equal to 1.
In a momentum, I
can say you would
be saying like you have a
particle for every unit volume
where size squared
integrates to 1.
So that's roughly the intuition.
And it's correct,
really, to use it there.
If you think of the flux
of incident particles--
so incident flux--
flux-- we think of it as
the probability current,
which is number of particles
per unit time per unit area.
So it's h bar over m, imaginary
part of the incident flux.
So I should use the incident
wave function, this phi
of r, gradient phi of r.
And phi was e to the ikz.
That was the incident particle.
So this Laplacian gives
you-- not Laplacian--
this gradient takes a
gradient, it produces an ik,
the rest gets canceled, and
the imaginary part gives you k.
So this is h bar k over m
times the unit vector z.
So that's the incident flux.
This can be thought as the
number of particles per unit
area and per unit time.
You can also think
of it intuitively
as rho times v.
The incident flux
is like the incident
current, the current density,
it's rho times v.
rho is phi squared--
phi squared.
But that's equal to 1.
And the velocity
of the particles
is the momentum over the mass.
But that's hk over m.
And if I put the direction,
I will have to put the z.
So it's kind of the
same thing, rho v,
the incident flux are all there.
So this is the denominator
of that big formula
we have there--
the incident flux.
Then we need the
number of particles
scattered per unit time.
We could do it with
a flux calculation.
Also, in spherical
coordinates, but I can also
do it intuitively.
So I'll do it intuitively.
You can try doing it using
a probability current.
So intuitively what do we have?
We have a d omega here.
And let's consider a
little volume element here.
So a little volume element.
Here you have r--
distance r-- a little vr.
So a small volume element here.
And let's calculate how
many particles there are
in this small little element.
So dn is number of particles
in the little volume--
volume.
So I must square
the wave function
and multiply by the volume.
That's what you would do.
So what is the square
of the wave function?
Now, we are talking about
the scattered wave function.
So I must take this part
of the wave function
and square it and
multiply by the volume.
So we will have f of
theta and phi times
e to the ikr over
r, all squared.
So that's the wave
function squared.
That's psi carat squared times
the air-- volume of this pill
box is r squared
d omega times dr.
r squared d omega is the
surface area of that little box.
dr is the little length there.
And, therefore, we have
that volume over there.
So things simplify
the n is equal,
therefore, the r
squared cancels,
and it's just f of theta
phi squared, d omega, dr.
So with all these
particles-- this
is the number of
particles inside the box.
But all these particles
will go through
in a little time dt, which is
equal to dr over the velocity.
This is the time to
go through the box--
through the box.
dt is dr over the velocity.
And the velocity is hk over m.
So dr times the momentum over
the mass, which is hk over m.
OK.
So we have dn, dt.
This is number of particles.
We divide them to form number
of particles per unit time.
So the ratio dn dt is the
numerator of this quantity
here--
is numerator dn [? dt. ?]
And what do we get?
The dr cancels and
we're dividing the ndt--
this factor goes
into the numerator,
so we get h bar k over m f
of theta phi squared d omega.
So this is the numerator of
that equation for the d sigma.
So let's compute-- finish that.
We finally-- I'm going to
get off our identification.
And what do we get?
We get d sigma is
the numerator there,
which is this quantity, h
bar k over m f of theta phi
squared times d omega over h
bar k over m, which is nice.
That all going to cancel.
And then we get the nice
formula that we were after.
This differential
cross section is just
determined by the
function f of theta phi
that we need to calculate.
f of theta phi is our goal.
If we have it, we have the
differential cross section.
Many people write this
formula this way--
d sigma, d omega is
equal to f of theta phi.
I think that's OK.
I think in many ways
this is a little clearer.
This small little
area associated
to a small little
angle is given by that.
This is a ratio of differentials
more than a derivative.
A derivative with
respect to solid angle
doesn't mean too much, I think.
So-- but this is another
way people write it.
And, finally, people
integrate this total cross
section is the integral
of the differential
cross section over--
looking at all solid angles.
So this means integrating f
of theta phi squared d omega.
And that's the
total cross section.
OK.
So we've set up the problem.
We-- what are the main
things that we've learned?
We have the scattering center.
We have our physical
condition of a wave coming in.
Our physical condition
that the wave comes out.
Those are represented here.
And this situation
is saying that this
is an approximate
solution for a wave--
a wave coming out modulated
by a theta and phi dependence
and your incoming wave.
This modulation is the thing
that captures the effect
of the potential and associates
to the strength of this
potential and its ability
to scatter a differ--
a cross section,
which is measurable--
which means a probability
of interaction--
capture the probability
of interaction.
This cross sections
are very important.
When you design an experiment
with an accelerator,
you want to have a cross
section is sufficiently large,
because this cross section
is going to tell you
how many particles your
detector is going to get.
Whether with the
flux that you have,
with the beam intensity
that you have,
you're going to get one Higgs
a day, or 500 Higgs's a day.
And it made a
difference for the LHC.
It began with a
few Higgs's a day,
and later, it's getting a
few hundred Higgs's a day.
So-- so those quantities
are pretty important.